Hello and welcome to mCoding!
This is James Murphy.
I am doing another giveaway. So, if you'd like
a professional license to PyCharm,
which is the editor that I'm currently using, then
check the description.
In this video, we're going over whether or not a bunch of
built-in things in Python make copies of your data.
This is actually inspired by one
of my previous videos.
I had a lot of commenters, rightfully worried
that looping over a list this way
in order to loop over it backwards
might be making a copy.
I got suggestions to use
a slice of a list instead.
And, in the wild, I've even seen people fall
back to using error-prone indices
just to avoid this issue.
Well, it's definitely clear this index-based
approach doesn't make a copy of my list.
But it's so much less readable.
So, I'm happy to tell you that reversed() does
not make a copy of your sequence.
If you want to loop over
something backwards, this is the way to do it.
This isn't a foolproof method to
tell whether or not a copy is made.
But we can actually get
an inclination that one is not made
by printing out
the reversed of the list.
Notice that instead of getting
an actual list back,
we get this list reverse
iterator object.
If you see something that says
like an iterator or a view or a generator,
that should be a clue that a copy
probably isn't being made.
Just for comparison, notice that if
we use this fancy slice of a list,
then we actually get
another list back.
So although it's shorter in this case,
it is also making a copy.
So then how is reversed() able to loop over
the list without making a copy?
Well, here's an implementation of a class
that acts the way that reversed does.
The key idea in all of these ways of iterating
is to define your own iterator.
An iterator is just an object that you can
repeatedly ask for elements.
The way that you ask it for an element is
by calling its __next__ method.
This is also what's called by
the built-in next function.
If there are any more elements left to iterate
over, then next returns the next one.
If there aren't any more elements to iterate
over, you signal that by raising a stop iteration.
Technically speaking, an iterator must also
have an __iter__ method that returns self.
This is a little bit confusing because the magic
__iter__ method is used to define an iterable, not an iterator.
Iterables are just things that you can ask
for an iterator from.
Whereas, an iterator you can think of
more as an in-flight stream of elements.
So all the return self really
says is that
if you want to get a stream of elements
from a stream of elements, just return the stream.
Most of the important logic
is in the next method.
So all we do when we construct the reversed
object is store reference to the sequence.
Initialize an index to the last
element of the sequence.
And do some error checking.
Every time you ask a reversed
for the next element,
it gives you the element
at its current index.
And then subtracts one
from the index.
The last or I guess first valid index is 0.
So, after returning that one,
our index gets set to -1.
So, if we see minus one, then
we know there are no more elements.
So as you can see this allows us to iterate
over the entire sequence without making a copy of it.
The built-in reverse is actually going to
do something more like this
that actually does things in terms
of this next method.
A common way to do something similar without
as much code is to use a generator instead.
This generator code
does essentially the same thing.
And is quite a bit clearer
in what it's doing.
But the major difference here is
that the error checking doesn't happen
until you actually start the generator
which happens when you
actually ask for the first element.
Whereas, the class solution did
the error checking in its init function.
Of course, doing error checking earlier rather
than later is usually a good idea.
But this is an option.
So then the question is:
Which of the major built-ins actually
make copies and which don't?
Aside from sorted, most of the built-in
that make copies are containers themselves.
And that kind of makes sense.
If you ask to make a new container using an
old one, then you're kind of asking to make a copy.
On the other hand, there are a
bunch of them that don't make copies.
So enumerate, filter, inter, map,
reversed, and zip,
any of the dictionary views and
generator comprehensions don't make copies.
Once again, you can mostly
tell by printing them out.
The ones that make copies look like
they've returned a new version of the original thing.
Whereas, the ones that don't make copies
are returning these special purpose looking objects.
As is often the case in Python though,
there are almost always exceptions.
You're able to change how a lot
of built-ins interact with your classes.
For instance, slicing a list
makes a copy.
Because that's the behavior
that the built-in list shows.
But you can define your own
get item method for your classes.
And do whatever you
want with it.
And that's exactly what NumPy arrays do.
Things are not looking good
if you just print it out.
Both of these objects
are numpy arrays.
So, you might think that
reversed is a copy.
But NumPy arrays are actually
just very thin views around raw memory.
And printing out the data attribute
of both of these arrays,
we see that they're sharing the
same exact memory object.
Contrary to the way that lists behave,
no copy was made here.
The way that NumPy achieves
this is by using strides.
Strides tell you how many bytes you need to jump if
you want to get to the next element of the array.
These are tuples instead of just numbers because
arrays can be multi-dimensional.
But for a 1D array, we basically
just have a number.
The `4` here tells me that from some element
I need to jump four bytes to get to the next one.
That's because NumPy chose a 32-bit
or 4 byte integer type for this array.
So, all I need to do to get
a reversed array
is start at the end and jump by negative
e 4 for each element instead of positive 4.
It's a very simple, clever and effective
way to do things efficiently.
I wouldn't expect anything less from NumPy.
And finally, we spend all this time talking
about how to avoid making copies of things.
But I have to say that copies
are not always bad.
Sometimes you really need
a copy.
The canonical example of when
you'd want to copy is
if you're iterating over something and
mutating it at the same time.
For instance, here I have a, b, c
mapped to 1, 2, 3.
I want to go into the dictionary and add
uppercase A, B and C with the same values 1, 2 and 3.
Seems simple enough.
Iterate over key value pairs.
Convert the key to uppercase and
assign it the same value.
It seems straightforward but we got
slapped with this runtime error.
Dictionary changes size during iteration.
If you're not familiar how dictionaries
are implemented in terms of hash tables,
this might be a very confusing error.
Why does Python care if I modify
something while I'm looping over it?
The very short and simple explanation
is that modifying the dictionary
might cause the dictionary to have to
move all the elements around.
If that were to happen then the iterator
might basically just lose its place.
The solution is to manually make the copy.
Making a copy here means that
we exhaust the iterator
and collect all the results
into the list.
So the iterator is completely done
before we ever start to modify
the dictionary.
So, there you have it.
I hope this helped a bit.
Don't forget about the giveaway
if you're interested in a
professional PyCharm license!
Of course, thank you to my fantastic
set of patrons and donors!
If you like my content,
hit that subscribe button.
And if you especially like it, please
consider becoming a patron or donor!
My team and I are also available
for Python and C++ consulting!
Thanks for watching! See you next time!